yeah hello and welcome to this video
about Game four of the World
Championship match it's the late release
but yeah they tend to play super long
games you can never do it really on the
date was played it will always be the
following day in Europe and had a really
busy day on this Wednesday so it done
was only possible now to start the
recording yeah let's get going and look
at game before I merely for again to my
surprise actually I thought that game
two was so depressing that ki can would
switch to something else but he wants to
try Magnus again or test him again in
the room yeah member says absolutely no
worm incentive to to change to something
else game two was a perfectly
comfortable drawer him with black so we
have the same position as in Game two
now kayaking plays rookie one which
would have been seen as the mandatory
almost only move like 20 years ago where
nobody played d3 this move that was
tested in Game two but now kayaking
comes back to that main move rookie 1b5
and castles so council actually seems to
be ready to play the marshal attack
after c3d five would have this notorious
marshal attack on Marshall gambit where
black is giving up a poor near the
center porn in exchange for rapidly
develop but it was not the only move but
the sister the old main line of this
opening and the black gets good
compensation down and the general
consensus is that it's very difficult
for why did you get something in these
positions even though it's a fairly safe
choice for item there are some lines
where black can never do much but it's
difficult for why to play for women
nowadays most players ago and for one of
the various end time marshals this is a
four page three sometimes we see d3 but
this is kind of
not making that much sense if you want
to play with d3 you can do that on move
6 and just skip the rookie one move ya
hear h3 let's play this is maybe the
most popular entire Marshall the reason
is for this move is that now g5 doesn't
work because in this kind of situation
yeah white is actually still having the
move Knight c3 available there's no porn
on c3 and this is believed to be y an
incorrect pawn sacrifice note that h3 is
actually useful so after Bishop d6 back
here and here there is no made threat on
h2o yeah big threat on h2 and Bishop d7
is the normal reply and now d-3 yeah
it's funny here actually black still can
play d5 this is a popular pawn sacrifice
that's something like that has been
played and now black can take or play 94
both with compensation not quite sure
what the latest word is but I think
black is okay there countin does not
play that maybe he feels giving up a
pawn so early on is unsuitable for World
Championship match um i mean i kind of
think the approach is correct in those
kind of complex positions he is right at
home with both colors the same for
kayaking of course but yeah why not play
such a complex position that is more
close with d6 nothing wrong with Adam
okay a three give some copy only for the
bishop Queen 37 that's not the only a
choice black can also go for other
setups 95 or 98 has been played
especially night be a tie like this is
comparable to the brea black actually
has the brayer setup but white has
played a 3 and d 3 instead of c 3 and d
4 which somehow cannot be an improvement
so this is something that I also like
quite a bit but Queen d7 of course is
perfectly fine by the world chamois
connecting looks and now we have a
typical
maneuver a rupee 8 Bishop f8 so black
has gotten in all the usual moves and it
seems that why this M it wasn't build up
on the Kings side he is keeping the
center somewhat more modest but by not
advancing it so early you can rather put
or shuffle pieces to the King side and
later do something yeah it's a slow
strategy but not uncommon this kind of
setup yeah this night clears the way
here for the Queen to be on f3 and the
queen is helping to make some pressure
on them on the Kings side here that move
age 6 I can turn out to be a weakness we
see that white has this idea Bishop
takes age 6 which here will be important
in the game cars now took only four I'm
sorry he played this first and then to
Ghani form yeah and now went Knight to
c4 and we come to an absolute key moment
in the game now I think all that made
perfect sense the knight on c6 is not
well placed it looks at protected square
so this maneuver made perfect sense the
night now is active on c4 looking at
this pawn and it has good squares to go
to to be six or to d6 so all that makes
sense but isn't there porn hanging on
age six yeah well as I mentioned this
queener it looks at this night and in
fact now kayaking did capture on age six
and yeah it's it's an interesting move
and it seems that if we recheck check
the game continuation it is not the best
move and probably yeah giving black Arab
a comfortable position but yeah there
are some other things to mention first
let's look at an alternative white
instead could have continued to build up
on the Kings side it could have played a
move like yeah maybe 9 2 g-3 or not G
for this is maybe the most
what's the right word down um yeah if
you want flexible if you look at these
Kings I'd play you need an ID for anyway
if you go here here it can still be
chosen later yeah blacks idea or what
sorry wise idea is to go for such a
position here where the night might come
come here or long term you can do
something on the edge file I think this
is probably roughly equal um Blackie I
think can be happy here the night on c4
is blocking this Bishop nicely and if it
wasn't for that I think white actually
would be slightly better here it's a
this King side play can be quite
annoying but the night is just having a
good post down making this Bishop look
somewhat bad so this is what why I
probably should do after this hmm there
are a couple of wild complications
possible causal could have taken on you
form here for example but this is not
probably all that grade yeah white it
has this interesting continuation you
can opt for this position and here and
if we do a counter six point six months
but the exchange why didn't exchange
down but what you should not
underestimate is that the light squares
now I extremely weak in black scale note
the week f5 Square and if white play
something like 93 for example he is
trying to go onto those squares and this
is extremely unclear of this pollution
there so I mean what is blacker to do if
you take care you know this is getting
dangerous green g6 on the on the cards
very dangerous position for black
kayaking took a long time with this
Bishop takes h6 and this is probably
what he calculated in the press
conference it seems that he said I heard
that he said I didn't watch it myself
that he had actually overlooked 26 and
this is a very good explanation for the
move
page six in a way why you went for it if
you somehow don't see this reply the
move looks very attractive yeah if black
is forced into this position on Ellen
and in exchange art then it's an
attractive option for why but Quincy six
is actually a strong move and kayaking
now had to readjust this is often
extremely uncomfortable yeah you have
overlooked a move and then all of a
sudden yeah you're faced with a
situation that you have not anticipated
at all so what is that you should do
first of all this Bishop is now just
hanging for good yeah the queen is
covering the night so the bishop has to
move um yeah but where to where to go
and this is also hanging on be too right
so your choice is limited um something
like and let's say you come to g5 here
then black bow chicka form is on that
square let porn quite a bit that move
doesn't make any sense but I and the
night Bishop is now hanging immediately
so it seems that the objectively best
move here is Bishop to see one that
covers with two as well and black now
gets this back on you for after move
like 93 I think that the position is
again probably roughly equal if you give
me a choice I take black probably this
is also because this is more of a
position that I could have as black but
and I think objectively this is probably
about equal quite likely actually that
the Queen's get traded him something
like this is a very plausible
continuation and them something like
that black seems more active but why
doesn't have any serious weakness so
that's probably roughly equal and after
a long thing I think roughly 15 16
minutes and okay I can play the move
Bishop takes e4 and if you want to see
something really funny
I'm going I'm recommending to go through
the archived live stream of from chest
when you form where Peter Svidler and
eric hanson did the commentary on that
game because when this move was played
Henson was absolutely sure what a
transmission error because he felt that
is so horrible it cannot be true and it
is a really funny study in facial
expressions like he actually has a has a
coffee mark I was drinking coffee and
and I thought he was really close to
like spit the coffee out here just for
pure shock because the movers seemed so
outlandish to him and well we have to
agree that that sets really a really bad
move a really bad more strategically
speaking we have to look at the position
like one moves later and then we will be
seen probably in clearer well this is
such a bad decision sorry Carlton has to
check with the pawn first of all yeah
this is not not doing anything why
discovering this and now it's a pawn up
the Queen has to stay on that night but
he doesn't mind to take with a pawn in
the first case even if it wasn't a
technical reason if you keep with a pawn
this pawn on c4 is extremely strong this
is not a weakness yeah it's a double
porn a part of a double pond construct
but the ponyo is actually limiting
freezing white screen side completely we
will see later in the game that the c7
porn actually gets lost but this is not
a big issue at all as this pawn alone is
completely devaluing White's queenside
the light squares here I extremely weak
be 3d 3 C 2 and so on so giving up the
supported Spanish bishop was really a
tremendous strategic mistake and very
surprising let this happen because it's
it doesn't really take play off of
in strength to evaluate this position as
clearly better for black he must have
been really taken aback by Queen c6 that
somehow he got ya bye bye the screen c6
that he it seems has overlooked that he
was somehow thrown off balance because
it's sometimes you make a decision and
you look at this later and so you think
what was I thinking it's very obvious
then like one or two moves later that
that something went wrong and you
clearly see it and evaluate correctly
but somehow when picturing the position
one moves earlier just when you
calculate you somehow have a mental
block and this is probably what happened
to you you should underestimate that
they have played a seven-hour game the
day before so this is all probably
taking apart or playing a partier yeah
so let's have a look at this in this
position again we should have to go back
and Carlton got the pawn back now so
what do we have White has a devalued
Queen side Black has two bishops and if
you look at the bishop pair the key
thing often is the extra bishop that you
have like both have a dark squared
bishop and what is the value of the
bishop pair that light squared Bishop
better be should be better then then the
wife nights okay it's their question
here any argument that this Bishop is
stronger then the night on h2 or the
night on f1 I guess not that Bishop is
tremendously strong and has various
ideas also to to be positioned
effectively on the board in this
diagonal for example also might be
attractive in the future the light
squares in general as I said a very weak
and it's very good to have a bishop like
that this is a fantastically good
position for black um computers tend to
give black like 0.7 0.8
but for a practical player this even
looks worse because black has a
completely free hand here in improving
the position and white has absolutely no
counter play so an excellent position
for Carl's an excellent opening result
the result of this is really blunder a
bishop takes you form so let's see how
it continued Nigeria was played and
night to be six not the only move their
engines suggest Queen g6 here mostly but
96 and i think is a good understandable
choice I already know what I would have
played but I think I also would have
leaned towards this move one key ideas
that white is also suffering from a
disadvantage in space a his God is
basically down to those three ranks well
black has things on the fourth and fifth
rank and more space and generally you
don't want to trade all that much the
white pieces are basically standing on
each other's toes if you want to look at
and where are those pieces potentially
positioned they kind of fight for two or
three squares mostly the III square and
therefore not training this make does
make white since end route d1
centralizing and God's not let you
create and we should mention that black
he had the opportunity to take here and
do this yeah big trade on f3 just
looking at the pawn structure this
position looks okay for black of course
yeah there's a doubled pawns
instructions our other pond construction
on the King side but you absolutely
never never ever give up this Bishop for
a knight on f3 this position while not
being super tractor for wide is probably
probably tenable you
the bishop on c1 to cover this weakness
I should unpainted a little bit much you
would put the bishop here to cover be
2nite you form my trade trade tonight
and in general you're fairly solid here
those doubled pawns are not a problem
because they are not exploitable you
cannot attack them so this would be a
gross position and error to take on f3 I
mean I think a good player wouldn't
wouldn't even think about the move so
cousin played route to be eight Bishop
see one that's the only purpose of that
Bishop now yet covering and b2 in the
long run f6 is a good supporting move
and now I'm kayaking was basically
running out of moves to play so we went
for the trade and put the night up to
2g4 so we've got an N ending almost as
an ending up without Queens still a
couple of pieces on the board but I
think it has clearly ending character
because Kings are not under fire anymore
it's um it's clearly very nice for black
one thing I ever which is something that
I know very well if you have a very good
position you sometimes are overwhelmed
by them by the sheer number of
possibilities it's not so easy in a very
good controlled position to choose the
right the right path because they all
look good yeah it's like yeah yeah and a
candy store and everything tastes nice
you don't know what to try to take and
this is sometimes make makes life
difficult my own advice if you are in
such a situation is often from a
practical point of view choose a move
that looks fairly simple in nature and
shoes it quickly this is often a good
practical show it's not spending ages to
find some miracle solution that might
that's mine but maybe it's not there at
all and just do something that makes
sense and improves your position in a
little bit and do that quickly don't
spend like 20 minutes on it and I think
cousin
and does something similar for couple of
moves he just slowly improves him look
to be five I think that that's a
sensible move the rook is a bit more
active there and it looks at 85 so it's
a further protection of this pawn so the
move f5 on is now in the position yeah
f3 played by um kayaking and you wanted
to I think blunt this Bishop and maybe
get an additional square there on f2 not
that this is great square but yeah it is
there now and what has to go the n93 is
not a good idea so went back to f2 and
Bishop is seven now yeah that also makes
sense it's not the only move I mean this
is the thing you have tons of moves here
and it's I mean you can theoretically
speaking spend a long time on figuring
out if you want to play let's say g6 in
this position or king of seven or Bishop
e7 they are all somewhat similar and
usually play one of those good-looking
moves I mean quickly means not in five
seconds but don't spend 20 minutes on it
it it won't let you much you have to
play slowly anyway I mean slowly in them
in HSN's yeah like slow build up slowly
improving the position councilman Bishop
e7 I mean you can argue here what's
better um I also feel king of seven
makes perfect sense i get this king
closer to the action it's not a it's not
a big big difference probably um ya que
aquí know when f4 he was tired of just
sitting there and very understandable
yeah just doing absolutely nothing is no
fun and not that this is a big attacking
move but it at least does something um
now again there's a choice councilman
bishop age form and it definitely
retains a substantial advantage i also
like the idea too
take him um and again it's very
difficult to say what's best in okay
what cannot take am be 2x so 92 was the
point and now yeah black should be
cautious with this one as 94 it's kind
of embarrassing that something like that
is oops here it's not a particularly
good idea what all of the Sun gets
activated and he's also as gotten rid of
this strong light squared Bishop it
looks like age for then furthered evalu
those pawns not good but black can't
simply continue with a move like this
for example and here here and play this
position which definitely is favorable
for black but this is the case with
every position your kind of yeah you
have to a kind of yeah try to find the
best move of many good moves and this is
off not so easy to do yeah it's it's
simpler to play only moves in a way and
because you just have to figure out the
rest losers I have to play that one so
it's not all that easy to determine
black here is also better but he is
better also with Garland's move Bishop
to H form and yeah ki can took only five
that's probably the best best choice um
yeah you could think of this year just
to to break break this yet break this
bind but it's not clear that you
actually have to go here to cavity six
but it's not clear that this is helping
you like ism I'm still the exchange up
for porn and when those pieces are not
really good and the stand that you did
not want to give up the exchange it took
only five and cause it took one g3 now
we get this trap this now yeah you could
even think about taking with the with
the bishop that wasn't terrible but it
makes sense to yet to get this porn
structure
improved yeah to tape um yeah this move
was now played back I aachen the move
rook to e7 here that look that looks
attractive is actually not a good idea
because you'll be five and why cannot
avoid the rook trade now ya know clap
mold made in the mids in one place and a
position like that we have to really be
absolutely clear on that this is just
down down right lost for what it's
nothing nothing more nothing less that's
losing because of this pawn structure
black is effectively a pawn up yeah it's
five against five but these rope three
pawns are completely healthy in mobile
and this thing no not so much your black
will just push the points forward and
probably win with with simple plain like
f-4e for now this is all supported by
the bishops so this is structure has to
be avoided he played hookie one King to
have seven that the King needs to needs
to calm rookie five or completely
completely logical and yeah here this is
one of those decisions where I really
don't know what what to make of it um
I'm and very certain that Khan's move
wasn't terrible or anything but this is
something where I really have no clear
concept of telling apart what's better
the question is he played rock t 5 which
yeah basically forces the rook traitor
why drew has nowhere to go and I
absolutely wouldn't be sure this is
desirable not in my own game my judgment
call would be to not create the rook
simply to to have more potential on the
board in a way but it should not really
spoil anything I mean absolutely not but
I cannot tell you what's better I mean
my gut feeling it would be to not trade
um just
do you have more on the board to work
with but I mean I think it's an okay who
I'm just saying it's a very difficult
decision do you want to trade or not um
with rook stranded the black king maybe
gets more potential it can now move
absolutely freely on the board with
roofs on the board this is often not not
that easy yeah black is clearly better
it's the same thing since move 17 and we
have traded down again to an ending
where Callicoon has to yeah play tough
defense in a pretty bad position a
difference I think we're between this
position and game 3 is that here the
defense is I mean it's not fun but it's
easier to do in Game three karaoke night
to calculate extremely precisely here
his position is basically one of his
neck spectator in the game is just doing
yes to make moves because it is a turn
but he doesn't have anything
constructive that he can do this is also
the difficult thing here for white he
has no clear-cut idea how a draw might
look like they're in Game three it was
like it was clear that he wanted to get
rid of all the points to draw rook and
night or draw with the blank rook
against look at night but there is no
clear concept here white will always be
worse in some way it's no there's
nothing clearly drawn yeah um or
something clearly drawn that looks
sensible to reach in a couple of moves
of course you can do all kinds of
fairytale things and I give a
traditionalist that I might have a draw
but it's not not something that can be
done in two or three steps I'm very very
uncomfortable the situation for the
Challenger Bishop g5 was played King g6
and now h4 that looks like a further
weakness not sure that was a good move
King age five
983 and yeah it's interesting now Bishop
f7 was played you should be seven it's
an interesting moment now because
council now takes on age four and this
is what I am want to save which is a
little bit surprising here he's not
playing this very patiently this
position black um maybe look at this
white has absolutely nothing that he can
do nothing and black could easily um
improve his position a little bit more
like Bishop defy for example Bishop t5
to you for something like that that this
point is not going away I mean obviously
not so raven 282 Bishop 25 the a bishop
if I was actually possible I was just
seeing a ghost there um something like
that you have time and somehow he does
not yeah display this patient was just a
which usually is one of his strong suits
he just has like place like he's got all
the time in the world in the ending
maybe he just evaluated this as
something that is very desirable to
trade age against the porn that might be
the case and black is still very very
clearly better but he did not yet have
to do it now he forced the action now in
some way and often in the ending it's
good to just play in somewhat let's say
in a min him in his style where you kind
of shuffle a little bit and do little
things so that you can actually also
give the other guys some leeway to do
something stupid yeah just to take your
time it's often the best approach um I
felt that quite often I've won good
positions by improving slowly and and
just
and window quicker and with something
drastic because if you do it slowly and
let the other guy kind of sit around a
little bit then they're bad position
they often do something stupid and
actually help you not saying that this
is this would have happened but doing it
slowly is often not a bad idea so what
happened to you a bishop went back to
the eighth and cousin brought the pawns
forward note that in effect black is a
pawn up here now the beat you pawn is
worthless absolutely worthless so this
is probably what brought him to to do
this straight and this is quick trade
because it's it's clear that it's very
favorable for black question is can you
win of course that's the big question
and i have to say i'm not able to answer
this absolutely correctly let's see what
happens yeah g4 now played by kayak and
this is one of those few key decisions
where where yes he can do more than just
sit around as I said earlier yeah this
is asking a very clear question what do
you do with this pawn tension and I
think um we we can go I won't move from
one move ahead or tumors this officially
585 I was kind of surprised smooth but
okay it's probably not doing all that
much um and this now played by a kanay
is even not protecting the porn on g4
and this is probably probably the the
key position here in the game I mean
more than one key position but one
absolute key position and cancel now
plate the move f4 pushing the pawn the f
porn forward and it's it's it's still
tough to say but I think it's the draw
after that I think it's a draw I mean I
watched the live broadcast and n svidler
and handsome
try to find a win for black and there
they failed they really failed and I'm
not spoiling too much I think you must
say that this game ends in a draw yeah
after f4 it's still last 50 rules by the
way it lasts a long time but it is
probably not possible to win this
position anymore as wide as getting
something that it's usually called a
fortress now something that it's just
game possible to breach and Carolyn
didn't succeed so probably pushing f4
here getting this pawn of the tour to a
passer wasn't the right decision um it's
difficult very difficult to evaluate if
you can win however in the first place I
feel it should there should be something
but um I cannot cannot tell some things
I can tell if black takes this is
probably not going to be winning if you
look at this position here this is very
nicely getting the black king out of the
position so I mean the black king is not
entering all that easily and white is
stopping the G pawns here on g3 I think
here it's quite imaginable that this
could be a flat draw right I mean black
is not really making much progress here
it tries to sneak in like that you block
it here probably not not much that black
can do if it tries to come around I mean
ok this this would be hanging now so
probably probably not all that great I
mean let's say we go here and black
tries to go around with the king yeah
like here right is mostly shuffling like
this
are you getting anywhere note that white
can also um yes which rolls here
sometimes night at nine and Bishop even
and also that's a for I just see that a
four is also possibility as it's not so
easy now for black to reroute this
bishop I think this is a draw
disposition if black black takes on
default maybe you should have just kept
the tension and this is what I referred
to earlier there is no need to play a
form you can always do that it's
probably impossible for white or at
least unadvisable a white to ever take
on f5 yeah if we imagine you would have
played Bishop is six a situation like
that looks very uncomfortable with the
black king actually threatening to come
in with the Jeep on it looks very
borderline very borderline so wiper
probably never take voluntarily on f5 so
there's no real reason to push a form
there is no need to do this now and Ella
said maybe it would have been wiser here
too just like shuffle around four-thirty
moves let's say and let let kayaking
plays clock down to two to less time if
that's what it was surprising it's
really also not Magnus estar you just
usually react like grinds this very
slowly and f4 was was played right here
right here I mean maybe if there is
someone finds the win yeah I mean it hit
some it someone would be a thing that
would be justice in that because whites
position really really sucks but it
might just hold it sometimes happens
that you can have a bad position somehow
but it's not winnable and yep chap there
is very little that can be that can be
done here
what council can try is to come around
with the king and this is what he did
and note the fortress type of character
here this is keeping the pieces out the
night is blocking this the bishop is on
d4 there is no way for the black king to
enter on the kingside this is basically
a barrier here now and so the King tries
on the queenside and you kind of think I
mean usually are very often those kind
of positions are somehow dismantled by
help of suits one that we get to a
situation where white cannot move and
look here I mean the King cannot move
this is always attacked but it seems
that there is no way to to somehow for
the concession from there from the white
side it seems to be not possible they
continued for a really long time and
understandable yeah they Carlton tried
all kinds of things back and forth yes
just nothing that she can do with it
every that was a try and later you even
try bhushan therefore but this is also
yeah not not leading to anything it's
it's mostly begging for them like it can
go back it's um it's just II kept didn't
even look at that before it has stopped
a little bit earlier and okay here we
see that there's no tambien forward
whatsoever yeah it's ninety four ninety
moves so what a strange game yeah okay I
can play this really inexplicable move
Bishop takes you for which which really
got him into huge trouble and count has
a great position but somehow even though
it's fantastically good in converting
technical advantages fails somehow for a
second time however like after game 3 m
in Game three
there were some positions where you
could clearly point out okay here that
was win and he didn't see it because he
didn't have time or whatever here this
is a really strange situation because
black must be in in great shape and was
for a long time for sure but it's it's
somehow impossible to prove a win or I
mean I didn't find any and also I think
most commentators didn't or most I don't
know of anybody maybe in the meantime
someone need somebody found something
also note that i'm using engines is
useless here because computers give like
minus 1.8 some some give minus 2 but if
you look at the engine then there's a
shuffle around aimlessly it's a it's
just that the engine adds up advantages
are better pawn structure we should bear
the king is more active there's a pawn
on AF file this is all nice and good but
if you have no way forward it's nothing
it's just nothing so very very very
interesting kind of kind of draw here
from this this position I wouldn't be
surprised if someone finds a concrete
win somewhere but I rather suspect that
it is here before f4 was played when
their foreign hmm I don't know I feel
that that it is a fortress after her
form but this is more of a gut feeling I
mean again swidler hands they didn't
find anything and I think sweta also did
did a recap and didn't find anything
there either yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this game it's the fourth
draw but we again this was a big
struggle it wasn't a boring game um what
to make of this by the way his cards now
very frustrated he's not happy i mean
certainly not happy because if he I mean
he should have won both games in some
way
and then the image would be over simply
a plus to score for the world champion
is end of match and in effect no it's
just equal yeah we start now we had all
been eight game match on the other hand
council can certainly view those games
is very one-sided yeah there wasn't a
single point ever in this match where he
was even like a single digit in engine
evaluation worse it was just quite the
opposite he's quite I mean don't get me
wrong easily getting good positions yeah
and like here and was handed to him like
here here you got it yeah and he just
just has to convert them which
eventually certainly will happen but it
can also be like we sometimes you were
other sports yeah man one team is
pressing all the time but they simply
don't score and then all of a sudden the
other team gets one single opportunity
to score and does so and also that that
might might happen we don't know and it
will be interesting to see Game five
obviously which will happen on Wednesday
Wednesday no thursday I'm sorry Thursday
the seventeenth yeah I hope you enjoyed
the coverage I'll be back with game five
as well thank you very much